but that's going to change but anyway yeah so here comes Evan back.
All right Rishi you can hear me but not see me right?
That's correct.
Okay good well we're currently streaming live now to Twitch.
Very excited we've had some tech issues trying to figure this out.
I can't be on Blab and Twitch at the same time.
So we are starting a new series answering questions from entrepreneurs who've emailed me in
while I play League of Legends and we'll see how well I can multitask and do this.
And my special guest and co-host is Rishi from the YouTube channel RishiCupTV.
Rishi how you doing?
Hey hey everyone I'm doing fabulous super excited to try this new idea that you have.
Uh JasonRiseOnline is on Twitch watching says hey Rishi.
So I am going to uh I'm gonna set up I'm gonna get into a ranked game here on League of Legends
and uh we're gonna get through some questions.
So the format is people have written in and uh Rishi's gonna ask the question
and then she's gonna answer it and then I'm gonna answer it.
I'm gonna move on to the next question and we'll see how we do while I queue up for my
ranked game.
So Rishi who is our first question?
Okay first question is Kevin Knight.
Kevin has got a question about and are you ready sir for this?
Are you ready for me to just rock with the question?
I'm I'm ready I'm ready.
Okay what's in a name Kevin says says I'm about to incorporate my business operations
and I've been thinking what would be the best name to give it.
Says I currently have one core business but I do not uh but I do have other interests
and so he basically yeah wants to know how important is this name but I'll just say he
does not give much info on the business that he's looking to name.
Okay so so what do you think what's in a name?
This is a really good question um I think for sure a lot is in a name because in this day and
age time goes so quickly you only have a second to grab people and so I'm thinking that if
anything the name is going to be your first impression and uh you want to grab people
in that first impression and at least tease them to what your business is about and the
value that you're going to be giving them.
So that's my first thought what do you think?
I like it uh I think I think people make a lot of mistakes in a name.
I think the advice that people are given generally in a name is uh tell me what you do
and then they end up calling themselves you know Oklahoma uh plumbers you know dot com or something
and it helps with the keywords and uh and it is very practical and does say what you do
but it's really limiting in that it doesn't speak to where you could potentially grow.
And I look at Hewlett-Packard, Hewlett-Packard started uh by creating oscillators you know it's
one little invention that they made and imagine if they called themselves you know Palo Alto
that's where they were from oscillators you know and how much that they've grown and changed since
then and I think it's just limiting to have a name that uh that just says exactly what you do today
because your company is likely going to change you know. When I first started EvanCarmichael.com
my company name my official company names I don't really talk about I guess but is Evan Carmichael
Communications uh and when I first started that I thought uh you know it was just a personal brand
is where I was going to be speaking and um you know I was doing a lot of traveling and speaking
so it's just a personal kind of business site and then as it grew I really I kicked myself and I
wish that uh I wish that I had found a better keyword name I wish I called myself like small
business secrets or something um but then as I moved back uh you know with time I realized that
I'm super happy that I didn't go that way I'm super happy that I kept it off my name because
my business is always an extension of myself and whatever I'm interested in doing like streaming
League of Legends while answering business questions I can do because it's off my name
and so if you look at like the most successful companies there are some common traits between
the names but the one thing that they don't have in common is that they don't say exactly what they
did and I think that's the biggest limiting factor with the name it also limits your thinking
like this is who we are and it becomes hard to break out of the mold because you put yourself
in that box and so I would um I would just caution against it there's a lot of different ways to name
a business like you look at Virgin they named themselves Virgin because they were all virgins
in business Apple came from just you know Steve Jobs was driving in the car with Wozniak and they
wanted they wanted a name that was ahead of Atari in the phone book because at the time you know
people use phone books and Atari was where Jobs used to work and he liked Apples so they called
it Apple and they said hey if we come up with a better name then we'll change it and they never
did so they kept it um yeah and so you know all over the place I look at Xerox they wanted a name
that uh was difficult to pronounce on purpose because once you remember it you'll never forget
it uh people have names named themselves after their own business right mine is named after
myself uh you know Hewlett-Packard was named after Hewlett-Packard lots of different examples
Nike was named after the Greek god of victory um so lots of examples but they don't like Nike
didn't call themselves uh sports running shoes sure right so I think that's the biggest danger
in um in naming yourself not to be too specific make it something that you can you can continue
to grow with uh as you build your business for those watching on the stream I'm going to uh I
can't connect it's not finding me a match so I'm gonna I'm gonna start it up again there
where did you come up we'll talk about the Rishi cup name you had some issues with that
and thinking about that and struggles and tribulations but tell the story there
yeah and so what I'm well what I'm understanding you're saying Evan is that the most important
thing is to really think more about what your values are versus what you do because the values
never change um is that is that kind of what I'm understanding you're saying
uh that can definitely be part of it it doesn't like values can be a big part of it like the
honest company is named after their one word which is honest um but you know
Hewlett-Packard is named after two people the founders okay not necessarily a value what I
was saying was it's not necessarily bad to name it after your house it's definitely a great way
to do it just don't name it after exactly what you do so you put yourself in a box
perfect yeah well um Rishi Cup TV is definitely for me becoming more and more the name is I guess
becoming more and more significant um because when I started out with Rishi Cup TV I didn't choose it
really having a a clear idea of what that even meant and I guess it's kind of similar to you
I guess it's kind of similar to you in that it's more naming my business after me than
naming it after what I do but I'm still in the process of kind of defining what that is and
what that means but well tell the story of the cup because you were on the fence should I keep
the cup not keep the cup yeah the cup the cup kind of just was like again the name for me
was a choice kind of intuitively and so I mean the cup for me means a lot of things but I'm a
coffee lover so there's just the very natural love for the coffee cup but I'm drinking coffee right
now I got it I got it on me I got my Tim Hortons well it's not really in a cup it's from Tim
Hortons but what what what kind of coffee are you drinking today I have a extra large decaf
double double which which in non-canadian speak is two two milk two oh I think it might
actually be two cream that's why it's so sweet I should do two milk two milk two sugar
but are you a decaf are you a decaf drinker normally I will drink decaf at night if I'm
having a coffee but because of the stomach issues that I've been having oh yeah one of the
recommendations is a cut back in caffeine and the there's a massive massive difference between
decaf and regular it's like 10 of the caffeine yeah which everybody told me like oh it's not
that big a difference uh maybe it's just Tim Hortons maybe Tim Hortons maybe these guys are
the only ones that have that big difference but um I looked at that I don't really I don't I don't
taste the difference and I don't need the caffeine to wake me up okay uh so I don't know if you can
actually taste caffeine oh I found the match very exciting um yeah so that's what I'm drinking but
back to your story they want to interrupt there no that's okay yeah I just I guess for me the cup
beyond being a coffee cup uh is a symbol for me kind of like what you were talking about like um
it's it kind of represents uh all the things that I want to share with people and so
I think it's the cup being a symbol for who I am what my message is is starting to be uh more and
more helpful for me because I don't think that message is going to change I mean I think it's
going to get refined and and all of that over time but for the most part that cup is symbolic of how
how I want to touch the world and so um hopefully that name is going to be helpful for me going
forward in communicating the message and one of the things that I really loved about the cup
is you start off when you're when you're coming on chats or streams of what's in the cup and it's
become this tradition where like people ask you what's in the cup it's like cup of love or cup
of appreciation or cup of whatever so you can know it reflects what you're feeling at the
moment so it's interesting I like it thanks are you set up on your end it's it's not no I was in
I was almost in a game and then they banned away my champion and then somebody left I just it's
never taken me this long to find a game but it allows me to focus on the questions a little more
so I wish I understood League of Legends I don't even know what you're dealing with on your end
right now well nothing yet I'm just waiting basically you got to wait for for nine people
to join so you can play with and against them oh wow but for some reason do you want me to do
you want me to feed you another question or yeah we got a next question and next time we'll get
it set up so you can hopefully see the twitch stream too well now here's the thing too I just
want to make sure because are you able to still get this I guess we need to wait for the game
are you still able to get the question for your video even though the game is not set up right
yeah yeah but this is all this is all being recorded this is good let's okay good all
right hit the next question comes from Jacqueline Lee she says I have a little struggle with my
startup and I hope you can help me out I have tried really hard to find funding for my business
but I have no investors who are willing to invest in a not-so-corporate startup and again she
didn't provide information really about what business she's in but she's looking for funding
and investors and needs help right and she didn't say how much right okay okay cool and and what
was her name again her name is Jacqueline Lee Jacqueline Jacqueline okay cool so what do you
think I said she needs to talk to Mark with this not-so-corporate podcast yeah that's true
Mark Drager is a friend of ours and actually we we did a video on the on my youtube channel that
did pretty well uh where he talked about how to build a how he built a million dollar plus
business so there's lots of yeah lots of interesting advice in that video um but yeah
sorry go ahead well I guess um kind of going back to what we were talking about is like the
more you know um who you are and the impact that you want to have the easier it will be for people
investors potential investors to get on board with what you're doing and so I I would I would
just recommend that maybe she has a very clear idea of what her startup how she plans to impact
the world with this startup so that you know potential investors can resonate or not resonate
with what it is that she's doing because not so corporate I'm sure there's a bunch of people out
there who are not so corporate who would be passionate about whatever it is that she wants to
um provide yeah it's interesting you know I think uh I don't know very many startups that are
corporate like people start a business because they don't want to be corporate they're not that
many corporate traditional startups it's kind of it's kind of an oxymoron um I think in terms of
looking for investors uh it depends on how much you're trying to raise I don't know if you're
talking like venture capital level where you're looking at half a million dollars plus or you
want a thousand dollars to you know buy some supplies and start the business I think either
way though um I think too many people focus on the funding at the start I think it's the wrong place
to start I think the best thing you can do is not go into debt and not bring on an investor
if you're if you're bringing on an investor you're going to be giving up a huge chunk of
your company like if you have zero revenue coming in right now you just have an idea
and you you bring on an equity investor you're going to you're just going to give up way too
much of your business it won't be valued fairly and as you grow and if you still need money to
market and expand that's when you want to bring on an investor because the risk is a lot lower for
them when you're starting though I also I'd love to see you prove it to yourself like show
yourself that it can work show yourself that it's worth putting your time and effort into you I I've
told I've said this a lot on the different you know streams and videos but I hate spending
money until I'm making money and I would try to find a way to hustle and bootstrap and make it
happen if you really are out of options I'd be looking at trying to find a job in the industry
that I want to learn from find someone who has already built the kind of company that you want
to build and go work for them and try to be more involved with them and be active with them and
they'll teach you how to run a business and you'll be making contacts and be making mistakes while
getting paid to do it and then the money that you do make from that you can invest into your
company but it'd be looking at hustling on the side bootstrapping going to go find a customer
and trying to spend as little money as possible and going on trying to get get a deal because
anybody can spend money and that's the risk for investors anybody can spend money not everybody
can make money and so you're gonna get you're gonna get destroyed in your valuation I have a
match found okay maybe we got to get the game how long we've been this crazy I've never never never
taken this long to find the game we'll see we'll see last time somebody quit oh no somebody quit
again this is crazy anyway well not nine people is a lot of people to wait for so I don't know
it usually happens a lot faster but we'll see to play might need to play like tetris instead
or something I'm kind of in right now we'll see I'm queuing up to see if anybody leaves anyway
um yeah I think too many people focus on the funding part and there are options you know
there's also government options um but you also spend most of your time then raising trying to
go out and raise funding instead of actually building your business wow and the best thing
you can do is just go out and try to find a customer and use the profits that you get from
bringing customers in to fuel your business growth and I know it sucks and it's hard and
you're thinking at the start you know I don't have enough money or I don't have anybody in my corner
and I'm not going to start until I get that funding but if you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs in the world you look at the people that you look up to you look at the people who've
had a ton of success um you'll you'll find that when they started they probably have they probably
had less resources than you already have right now that's a good one you know Oprah when she
started like when she she was growing up she had no money she had to wear uh she broke a significant
chunk of her time with her um grandmother who was totally broke and Oprah had to go to school
with um potato like they took potato bags and it turned that into a dress for her
it's been the fourth to buy clothes so she wore potato bags to school oh my gosh and everybody
of course made fun of her oh I'm getting yelled at in the chat because I banged somebody's champion
I thought you wanted me to ban that oops my bad making mistakes with the uh with the the split
focus um yeah so reminds me you tweeted something out I'm looking for it yesterday you tweeted
something out that was so good I'm looking for it now but um about how to be resourceful you know
um but anyway go ahead sorry no just just saying that what I would encourage you to do is go look
at you know successful entrepreneurs you look up to people that you you know you respect and love
and cherish and you know your idols and role models and look at how they started and chances
are they didn't have an investor they didn't have you know a rich uncle backing them they didn't
have a venture capitalist they just started and don't use the lack of resources as an excuse for
you not getting started because a lot of people will take that and say I you know I'm not doing
this until this happens until I get funded or until you know whatever case happens right
and you're always waiting for the perfect time to start a business where
just like having a kid you know there is no perfect time you just you just start you just do
it so just do it find a way to get started it's always about the how resourceful you are instead
of how many resources you have and that's the hallmark of an entrepreneur is being able to
see something when nobody else sees it and and turn mud into gold because you're just
super resourceful so don't don't I mean honestly I wouldn't I wouldn't waste my time right I would
not be where I spend my time trying to find an investor I've been looking at helping to hustle
and lose wrap it up all right we got a game everybody accepted this is very exciting
I'm playing a new champion that I just started playing today so I'll probably suck you more
than usual word of warning to the viewers I'm not a very good League of Legends player but
I will do my best all right all right any follow up or you want to hit the next question
no that was great all right all right this is Mehdi from Iran he says hi Evan I'm a CEO at
Revics Revics on we are about to face a big failure in our business we are selling music
instruments like guitars and violins our customers are cut by half this year and it says he said I
just saw a video you guys mess you guys messaged about renting dj equipment you told him to give
his customers a message what can this message be because we are the same as this guy so it
looks like there was a video that went out where you you told a dj renting company to give a message
um anyway and what is he failing what is he um what is he selling it looks like he sells music
instruments and guitars and violins okay I'm gonna I'm gonna mute this here so we don't get
too much uh background volume okay so he sells instruments and violins yeah and he's they're
failing they just got cut their customers got cut in half this year yeah and what do they do
okay what do you think uh well it sounds like he's really resonating with your uh your message
about giving a message so it sounds like maybe he's not really differentiating or standing out
his business from any other guitar violin business so maybe they're losing business
because they're not really standing out and so I'm thinking how are you unique how are you
different what can give you an edge from every other music business out there so that people
will come to you instead of going somewhere else I'm thinking of your message stand out by standing
up um yeah that may be the video that you watched maybe yeah it's an interesting it's an
interesting business I'm wondering why it's um why the business isn't doing well like why are
they losing people and who the main audience is is it is it young people that they're losing
or is it you know older people like what their age and their demo is because that will give
a little bit of feedback as to how to how to you know fix the problem um but yeah you know so even
if the market is shrinking even if it is declining understanding what it is that you stand for as a
business helps right like when somebody's buying from you they're not just buying uh the product
or service you're selling they're buying more they're buying the values of the business and so
I look at uh the Toronto Dance Salsa as an example it's a company that I've invested in and I'm
however you know I'm an owner now you know major role in and the theme there is about family
where we treat everybody like their family uh and people who come don't come just to
learn how to dance but they come because they want to feel connected and be part of a community
and they want to you know most people don't come and sign up to be the world's greatest salsa dancer
they come because they want something fun to do in their life they're bored they want to meet
somebody and so what's the real reason behind somebody wanting to come and learn how to play
a guitar or a violin like what's the major reason behind it what's the emotional connection you can
get behind it uh and then tap into that as being your main message your message should come from
a core value like what do you want to see in the world and how can you be a beacon uh of
you know intelligence for that so for me it's believe you know all of my videos are about
believe everything I do is about believe uh you know the youtube channel my website everything
that I do uh it's just in me like I believe in people I can't help it uh I want people to do well
and if if if I look at what would I do otherwise like if I wasn't a youtuber you know what would
I do if I didn't understand business what would I do I'd be believing in people some other way you
know uh I'd be believing in salsa dancers I'd be believing in kids I'd be believing in you know
athletes something it's just it's part of who I am and I want people to believe in themselves more
and I try to spread that message and so there's a lot of different people you can go to
for business advice uh you know people come to me not everybody like some people may hate the
message some people say believe that that's really stupid uh and that's awesome you know
like we're not gonna probably get along very well that's not awesome well
that may not be awesome but like you know I don't need to get into battles and fight them
it by stating up front you know your your values and it helps people to
to self-select in or out and I think that's important yeah um what might be some other
factors like let's say he does have his message and he's still failing where would you tell him
to go next right so with you it's a great question if you're doing like so sales marketing you're
trying to get your business up the first part is is the the core selling which is what we talked
about right so get that message down uh the easiest way to then grow your business is
is to look at alliances so I'd be looking at who else is already selling to these guys and how can
I partner with them so this is then again understanding I'm pretty sure he understands
uh who his audience is but say for example that it's uh young people right he's selling to
high schoolers then who else is connecting with high schoolers and how can you partner up with
them to create some kind of alliance that works for everybody uh I'd be looking at you know
youtubers in your area or people who are big on instagram and how can I help you know if for
example there's somebody who's really big on instagram or youtube in my local area right I
try to have them come in and learn how to play guitar and teach them a lesson right and showcase
that they learned this at you know your school uh so again the fastest way to grow your business
is to find people who are already selling to your target audience and find a way to connect with
them and the easiest way to connect with them is over that shared value right if you go in and just
say hey uh you know I like selling instruments to kids uh can you help promote me that's not an
easy yes where if you are trying to help promote say it's confidence right you believe that you
know people kids get more confident when they learn music and that's your mission is to make
kids more confident that's something that like touches the soul a little bit more that's something
that's a lot easier for people to want to get on board with and be a part of uh and so until you
get the message it's harder to reach out and have success but once you do then all of those usual
marketing tactics uh work out well you know talking to the media doing strategic alliances
and partnerships super helpful to help you actually grow the business awesome all right
i kind of went on a rant there but that was good stuff absolutely you made a video this
morning about asking for help and i think just the fact that medhi asked for help uh in the situation
where he's failing is a huge step forward you know just being like able to realize that i'm i
don't have what it is i need to get to the next level and so that's kind of what you're talking
about alliances and and and just get building a support around you and anyway good stuff i love
it well so while that happened i got my first kill so we're doing well here we're doing my
team is winning i got a kill i'm pretty excited so far so good on the multitasking here i'm feeling
this yeah it's awesome okay here we go next question next we've got anna the artist and
i love artists i mean artists don't get enough respect or love as entrepreneurs wow and a lot
of people might not know that you actually uh have done a lot with artists so you've invested
in a lot of art right and helped art businesses and all of that people might not know that that's
really cool yeah uh wow there's there's a nice quote like the earth without art is a
like eh like the earth without art is eh and uh yeah yeah i think uh i mean i think if we go
a little meta i think everybody's an artist just how we express our art is different you know i
express my art through entrepreneurship uh i am a terrible although i i can dance i'll say that
although i sucked when i first started but i can dance but i can't sing if you want to hear some
great singing you can listen to rishi's channel because she's every what every week you have a
new song right every week everyone i don't know how that's crazy a new song every single week
that's that's an insane amount of dedication to make that happen um anyway i don't know how people
do it but but i don't think artists get enough respect as entrepreneurs uh and they need help
and you don't learn like you go to you go to a music class you don't learn how to be an
entrepreneur you learn the technique of being a musician but how do you turn that into something
you can build a career off of you know nobody tells you that stuff so anyway my quits before
even getting to the question that's my rant on it's good it's a good rant because i think artists
really are lacking well i don't want to make a sweeping generalization but i know coming from
an artist family i mean we had a lot of talent but it sometimes you don't have the entrepreneurial
know-how so i absolutely love this question anna says i don't like putting my art in large
galleries because there's uh so many other artists like 500 to a thousand other art pieces
that are being represented in the galleries and so when you walk in you're bombarded with
pictures sort of crammed together covering all the walls every inch
uh space is taken up and she says uh anyway
uh it looks like i i'm trying to find the question but basically it sounds like
galleries for her are overcrowded uh she doesn't want to do her art there so what do you think
what do you think she should do if she doesn't want to put her art in the galleries okay
what do you think
well um i don't know the visual art space but i do know that like the music industry has completely
changed where now you know i mean people still do go out to see music but so much is online now
online now and i just wonder if she's aware of what opportunities there are for artists i mean
you just had a video up with a visual artist i can't remember his name but it was all about how
to use youtube and use different online opportunities to really make a living off of
your art so i guess my first question to her would be has she looked into her options as far as
um online i know that there are online galleries but i don't know much about them
what was that noise it sounds like coffee
i was just gonna say i i am in starbucks for those of you who are hearing um
the frappuccino machine oh man i want a frappe now listen to that holy cow
um so okay so this is interesting so i think if you look at the art gallery model it's it's back
to the other question we dealt with of how do i get my name out there having um having partnerships
and alliances helps right so art galleries they're already selling to your target market right and so
uh being able to connect with them can help now it's one finding the right art gallery and two
it could be on you um i just died so that sucks i thought i had a kill there but i was i was i
felt like i was close i had no backup and i died so anyway i'm one and one right now moving strong
so if you don't go to the art galleries what's the backup plan like how else you're going to
promote yourself right art galleries are one way to do it but if it's not working for you
fine what are you going to do instead and i think that's the the bigger issue so are you going to
try to be online and and have a youtube channel and show how you do your art and build up your
name for yourself are you going to try to uh you know are you going to try to get into the media
and talk about your art and talk about the message that you stand for and try to get more
collaborations are you going to try to you know partner up with people in different kinds of art
forms uh you know and if you're a visual artist you know maybe you you paint the picture of a of a
of a you know celebrity at the time or a youtuber or you know it's the election right now maybe you
put it you put it a picture of donald trump versus hillary clinton but in your own style with the
message that you want to share like as an example if you are if you were about um if your one word
was peace or harmony and that was kind of what you stood for then you could do a picture in your
style of trump and clinton dancing together or something right like that would get some attention
that would get some notoriety that would make people talk uh because you have a powerful
mission that you're on uh if you do go i wouldn't necessarily give up on the art gallery route
if i was in an art gallery and this is now beyond just artists this is any entrepreneur you get
distribution it's the same thing you write a book you're going to get buried in a bookstore
you know you you uh get into walmart you're going to be one of how many thousands of products i
would work my hardest to stand out at that art gallery i would be there i would have times where
you know they get patrons coming by could talk to the artist i would try to help promote them
social media so that you know maybe they give me a better spot i'd be looking at you know you're
hustling you're being resourceful like how can you get a better spot in an art gallery what more
value can you bring to help them out uh so that you don't get buried you know the back of the
gallery somewhere but you are given a more prominent spot because you're really helping them
um so those two things i think could be really valuable one like the art gallery model may
really work uh but you have to make it work you can't just rely on them to do everything
uh and then two what are your backup options what else are you going to do to get your name out
because at least the gallery is doing something you know if you take that away then what are you
going to do to make it work on your own and hopefully some of the options that i talked
about uh can help you that's great my uh my teammate is really upset at me because he went
into a bad fight and i didn't follow him and he's like why don't you follow me so anyway people
rage you never know what you're gonna get in the game of league of legends that's right yep all
right so andy mo the engineer engineer all right engineers are also artists oh yeah absolutely um
i started my company a month ago i lost sense of direction and i'm no longer sure if what i am
designing is a product that will sell or will will it be useless i can't find a proper reliable
partner to share with me that dream what what do you advise and then he has a little uh at the end
my business model is to design a product make a brochure using 3d models i produced make a
prototype and make a good contract with customer then offshore the production you will understand
that more than i will okay okay so yeah what do you got for andy mo the engineer who is basically
lost his direction doesn't know he can find a partner
oh are you gonna ask me yeah i'm saying i've got a lot but what do you have
it starts with reishi answering oh okay um well
i don't think that i have a lot of knowledge at all in terms about of engineering but um
yeah i guess it sounds like the main thing is that he feels like he's lost his motivation
and so i guess i would ask andy you know what is going to get you back to a place where
you feel like you're excited about this product that you're designing um because if you're
at a place where you're questioning whether this is the direction then you know i think the first
step is why am i why do i feel lost why do i not exactly know what direction i want to go i think
all the other stuff will fall in line once you can tap into that place of excitement again
because the partner you know you can't find a lot you know everybody else that's going to be
helpful to you in the process will come i think once you feel like you've got your excitement
back and you know why you're doing what you're doing um so i would ask why why are you doing this
what's the why behind why you're doing what you're doing and
and i think that first step will help all the other things fall in line
cool i don't know if you hear like mad clicking happening here but uh
yeah that's okay we're trying to go i hear it we're trying to go get dragging right now
okay so i hear two things one i hear the frustration
of um of having a product that's not you know he's not sure of anymore it's not working anymore
and two was the lack of a partner and you know not sure not sure how to find a partner
to help him grow the business is that is that wow you're good i'm really good good job okay
doing a video game and kicking that out yep uh it's harder than i thought it would be actually
but but we're doing it we're doing it uh if anything i'm neglecting my team here
to listen i'm getting some hate i'm getting some hate from the team uh but i'm not doing my job
enough but it's not not serious so does your team that they don't know that you're multitasking
if they did i don't know they might be happy or probably not this is a right game which means that
if you like this counts towards your score so everybody has a has a has a score and if you
lose and it's bad oh man so i'm playing the right game anyway um it's okay i'm doing better than
they are so i could i could do better but i'm doing better than they are so um okay so for
the first part about uh having lost confidence in the product i think it comes down to a few things
uh one understanding again like why you started this like was it your own need or did you think
people would be interested in it was it your own frustration uh you know where did the original
idea come from and is that is that problem kind of does it still exist right you know engineers
solve problems that's what engineers do so does the problem still exist and uh can you go about
it a different way of solving it or not like can you talk to people can you get more feedback
i think one of the biggest challenges for people is they build something thinking that there's a
market for it and then they realize that nobody actually cared about it um you know i had this
problem in my first software company where we built something that we thought was amazing and
my uh my partners were actually in the field so it wasn't like people were just you know doing
whatever they wanted you know they actually had this problem but not enough other people had the
same problem and we we built a whole bunch of functionality that at the end of the day people
didn't want they didn't care about uh luckily we had enough in the product that we could still
build something and still make something from it but we wasted a lot of time going in the wrong
direction building features that people didn't care about uh so i think it's important to tap
into you know is there actually a need for it do do people care uh and and then do your best to
um now i'm in the middle of a battle just kill somebody so there's some distraction there but
i gotta kill and then assist so it's pretty exciting um basically going back to the roots
of like if this was just something in your head then that's going to be a problem you need to
talk to customers you need to get some feedback you need to see if it's if it's going to you know
actually work out or not uh and so tap back into that like why did you initially start this and
and maybe that your idea just like maybe it wasn't good enough yet and that doesn't necessarily have
to discourage you from being an entrepreneur you know you just might have to shift focus right um
maybe there's something that's useful in what you have created that you can tweak and modify um you
know as an example if i go back to that software company that we had the the most complicated
feature that we had in this in the tool was the ability to do undo redo as many times as you want
it so you can undo i just got another kill very exciting you can undo uh like if you think about
you make a mistake you can undo it right you can undo you can undo or you can undo and that was
apparently very complicated for my partners to do i don't know how complex it actually is but for
them they said it was the most complicated thing it turns out our customers didn't care
you know they didn't care at all about it like if we can go back 10 steps
that's fine we don't need to go back all the way to the beginning of using the tool uh so
that's a big blow like it sucks to spend a lot of time on something and then realize that nobody
actually cares about it uh now luckily again we had enough in the other thing that in the rest
of the in the rest of the tool that people did care about it but i'd be looking at you know
how can i modify my product so that it is more valuable and start talking to customers and get
some feedback uh and then take it from there uh hopefully that gets you a better product now in
terms of the partners this is another thing kind of like the funding like yeah i can't do this
until i get a partner uh don't let that hold you back too many people are held back by that they
oh you know i i really want to do it but i can't because i don't have a partner so i'll never be
successful uh start like you need to start regardless be resourceful and a partner still
may be the the option for you but don't let it be um don't let it be such a big deal for you
that you don't actually get going on building your business in terms of finding a partner
for me it still comes down to uh understanding what you stand for we've talked this is a recurring
theme here on this episode understanding what you stand for uh so you can attract the people with
the right values because you may say well i'm an engineer so i need a salesperson to join me
great just because somebody has the skills on paper doesn't mean they're going to be a good
fit with you right uh just like in any relationship if you are if you're looking to
get married you know um if you're a guy you know the fact that she's a girl is not enough of a
criteria right that's a good point it's just not enough of a criteria uh and so i think too many
people make that mistake uh it looks good on paper right like oh this person's so good at
sales it's going to be such a great fit and then and everybody's super just like in any relationship
there's a honeymoon phase you're super happy at the start but then you run into problems and uh
and i think that's a big challenge for a lot of people they don't do enough homework you know you
want to date before you get married you want to you want to make sure that uh you guys get along
as human beings and you share the same values as well as sharing the same mission and i think
because a lot of people aren't clear in what their values are then they it's just it's just uh what's
the expression just luck of the draw right like you're just hoping that it works out with this
person and then what happens with a lot of people is they get so frustrated because the first one
didn't work out then they say oh well i can never be successful i can never you know i can never
have a partner and then they just give up completely wow that is that is so un underestimated
the the need to know your value and to know the values of others and how they align or don't align
i can't more stamp a yes on that point that you made i like it well i said all that while my team
is raging on me raging one of my teammates is raging hardcore on me but i have three kills and
one assist friends okay i am i'm doing well compared to them so we'll see what happens
anyway good i like it i like i like the i like the question because i think a lot of people do uh
restrict themselves for both of them both in terms like oh my product sucks so i'm gonna give up or
oh i can't do anything till i have a partner so yeah and to that last point i found the tweet
that you put out it says we don't have the money the connection or the support but we don't make
excuses i like it well i tweeted it but i still like it hey you gotta like your own stuff that's
right it's funny somebody asked me i forget where it was an interview or something somebody asked
yeah it was the i saw that one yeah go ahead sorry yeah well somebody asked you know what
was your favorite youtube channel and yeah right somebody asked me what my favorite youtube channel
was and and it's my own you know like i love my channel i think you have to be and it's not like
in an egotistical way that oh my channel yeah you know you guys all suck and yeah just i love my
channel i love what i'm creating and i think as entrepreneurs you you know if you make shoes and
somebody asks you what's your favorite shoe how is it not your own right like you don't love your
shoes i don't know i think you can be confident in your in your product or service without being
insanely egotistical um but yeah i don't know i i answered the question that you wanted which
was like other youtube channels too which is fine but but i love my youtube channel you know
and if somebody asks me what my favorite youtube channel is i'm gonna say my own
well we love it too we love it too
all right um what's next one is a very long name uh chook one year and
wha wow sorry sorry if i killed that mr maxwell i'm just gonna call him mr maxwell for this maxwell
yep and he says i'm an aspiring entrepreneur he wants uh he says can you mentor me to success
i love your passion for business a little boy from nigeria what can you do to help me
especially in skills and it says skills accusation but i think maybe he means
skills i don't know do you have some just overall mentoring advice for an aspiring entrepreneur
okay from nigeria sure what's yours oh snap okay um my i think my advice is um
that i i keep i guess it goes kind of back to the what you were saying about the limiting beliefs
like no matter where you are what you don't have um you know i don't know what what he is working
with or what the businesses that he's pursuing but just to know that you can start where you are
to know that you can start where you are with very little with nothing i mean
i started my youtube channel on my ipad yeah still i still do it on my ipad i
record all my music on my ipad like it's someday some days i'm like super sad that's my what they
call a da your your music um set up but i i just make it happen because i just believe in this so
um i guess i would just say that uh you can make anything happen where you are with what you have
bread box studios i love the name that that's reishi's studio name well my team wants to
surrender because we're losing here but we'll see we'll see we'll see maybe we can pull it out
maybe we can pull it out never surrender oh i died all right um so this is an interesting
question and one you know congrats on reaching out this is maxwell right maxwell this is yeah
maxwell his last name is maxwell his first name is right okay um
one congrats on reaching out i mean i i wish youtube was around when i was getting started
as an entrepreneur there's so many people to connect with so many you know videos so many
resources um i wish it was around honestly because and congrats for you to doing it i think the the
the number one advice i always give to young entrepreneurs is you have to do something that
you're insanely passionate about uh if you look at famous entrepreneurs and the advice that they
look at famous entrepreneurs and the advice that they give it's always it's always that like it's
the most it's the most common piece of advice across any not even successful entrepreneurs
just successful people period you know if you want to be uh if you love accounting you know
like that is your insane passion you love accounting uh those are the guys who rise to be
the top of the accounting firms if you are just doing it as a job you're never going to be at the
top if you look at the people at the top of any field entrepreneurs or otherwise they always had
an insane love for what they're doing uh and so that's always the default place that i start
i think for whatever reason um we are trained somewhere to think that you gotta chase the money
and people get suckered into all sorts of different make money quick kind of opportunities
and you know more times than not you just end up losing money instead of making it and wasting a
lot of time and energy uh starting business one of the hardest things you're ever going to do
i know it's it's super kind of sexy and and you know in vogue and trendy everybody wants to be a
entrepreneur but uh it's going to be so difficult that if you don't absolutely love it you're going
to quit as soon as it gets hard like it's going to get hard it's going to get insanely hard and
i don't think people talk enough about how hard uh it gets as an entrepreneur you just you just
hear like the success stories of people who made it but not all the crap that they have to go
through uh and entrepreneurs in general and i was like this too you don't share the um you don't
share the problems when they come up right i remember when i was starting my business i would
always just talk about you know even if i was on dead broke somebody asked me how i was doing
like yeah i'm good i'm i'm i'm yeah yeah things are going well like it's just it's embarrassing
to feel like a failure right um so you know expect it prepare for it like it's gonna happen
and that's okay um so that would be that that would be my advice like it's it's
like you gotta love it you gotta love you gotta love it first of all and then get ready for
a battle and and and the love of what you do will get you through uh all the hard times
yeah and just like this guy is asking you i mean i there's so many people who are
asking you all the time will you mentor me and i think uh continue to watch videos
because just like i always say this like watching uh believe model the masters channel with evan
kronmichael is literally just like free entrepreneurial university it's like you can get
pretty much what you need in a video so i would recommend since he's in nigeria you know he may
not have someone in his local area but he can watch youtube and there's so much you can learn
so yeah and i think too just touching on mentorship in terms of reaching out and connecting with people
people are often willing to help especially helping young people if you show willingness
to want to learn and get better but i would watch out of just asking a total stranger will
you mentor me because it implies a relationship um and so i would ask start with a question like
the best thing you could do is is take what i've told you you want to you want to start a mentorship
relationship take what i told you and do something about it and then come back and say hey i did this
what's next tell me what's next because the there's so many uh
fake wannabe mentees who want the advice but don't want to put in the work and there's nothing more
frustrating for a mentor than having a mentee who doesn't want to put in the work and so you
need to stand out for all the people who say that you know they want to be mentored by me or whoever
you need to stand out by actually doing the things that you know you get the wisdom to do
so my little rant on mentorship go ahead on rants losing a game makes me go on rants
just remember to kill your uh kill your game opponents not
not anybody that's not the people asking questions no no no it's true
okay all right next question comes from madi who um
i think it might be short for marisol um or maribel i can't remember it was i shortened
these anyway sorry uh she actually doesn't have a direct question but it she's starting a
she wants to start a blog called doodle journey okay doodle journey and it's basically um
restarting our in her words restarting our schooling from scratch but this time self-taught
through the internet in our own studies huh um and she wants to use this doodle journey blog
to post the journey uh but the thing that she i think is looking to you for is she's trying to
kind of nail down what she what to pursue because she has a love for so many things
um she goes on to list that she has a love for being neat and organized for researching things
diy tutorials hobbies um so she has a bunch of different things that she loves um she wants to
be an entrepreneur uh but kind of i think needs direction because she has all these different
interests i i didn't fully understand the the question well there isn't really a direct
question i got the i got the question of like where to focus but i didn't fully understand
the mission she wants to okay she's trying to start a channel but um sorry she's trying to
start something to to for schooling it looks like for herself or for for kids uh it doesn't say okay
okay well i like the theme right i like that there's so many people oh sorry you know what
rishi what do you think i was hoping you'd just go i just went into it like wait a minute
this is tag team effort you can't just okay you gotta you gotta answer too all right well there's
this uh there's this amazing video that i will recommend that she watches by elizabeth gilbert
and it's called the flight of a hummingbird and it just basically it talks about following your
curiosity and not necessarily trying to figure out the the big huge one thing passion if you're not
sure what to do or where to start um and i like it because i can so relate with years of not knowing
what to pursue and having a whole bunch of interests and you know i don't know evan it
sounds like you're someone who and i think there are different types of people but it sounds like
you're the type of person who kind of knew pretty quickly once you got into that space of helping
entrepreneurs once you got that bug you were just it was the fire was lit and it was single
minded forward full steam ahead um whereas some of us don't always have that really clear
cut passion so i would say to her if she's trying to figure out where to focus just start by
experimenting with the things that you do love um and trying trying different things on a small
scale that are like low risk to see if you come alive and it excites you and you're passionate
and then i would um you know go from there i don't know if i'm helping her question in terms of this
doodle journey blog because i don't know i don't know if her question specifically in terms of that
but to me it seems like she's she was looking for what to do when you just have so many different
interests and hobbies and things and you want to start a business but you don't know where to start
right yeah so my my thinking here is i would try to find a way to combine them i think that they
all fit under your um your mission which is to teach people how to learn on their own without
having to go through a formal schooling process right that's kind of what i that's what i was
trying to clarify what the mission was i feel like that was it um yeah i think you hit it
i think you're right so if your mission is to teach people to learn outside of the formal
schooling system then anything that deals with learning is relevant and interesting right so
all of these things if you're teaching people how to learn to do any of it it's all relevant
and helpful and practical and applicable um wow that's so good so that's what i would say i think
i think you're you're if you start with the if you start with the the mission and the goals and
what you're all about uh and people will be on board with it right people like yeah i want to
learn how to at a homeschool or unschool or learn on my own or find resources uh i love that mission
then you provide them the tools based on what your own interests are right so if you really
love i forget what one of them was organizing right organizing was one yeah organizing
people are saying in the chat i've never seen i was gonna say you just started killing someone
again no no no they're saying i've never seen somebody play this passively
and the other guy saying well at least he's not just feeding the other team
come on guys i'm doing five kills holy cow haters haters haters everywhere man haters everywhere
anyway okay um yeah yeah so and i died embracing embracing geniuses again get people on board with
your mission what you're all about what you're trying to do you'll get people who uh are in
tune with that and then we take people on your journey or on other people's journeys so if
you're trying to do it for kids as an example uh bring on you know i have a six-year-old so
bring on a six-year-old and teach them how to organize teach them how to draw captain america
or whatever it is uh and by that person learning that the people who are watching are learning as
well so i think you can you can cover a lot of different topics you can cover a lot of different
angles um and i think that that's that's the secret like if you just box yourself in to only
talk about organization then you're not gonna be happy you know you're gonna have all these other
pieces that you want to incorporate and you should incorporate you know if i only did one kind of
video on my channel i would get frustrated i would want to change it and if you look at the evolution
of my channel i i've changed it a lot uh over the years like the style the format the type
of videos that i do they still are about believe the common theme but the how i do the videos are
totally different and so as an entrepreneur you want to have that freedom to be always uh
the full expression of yourself and as you change that will change as well uh so embrace the genius
of the end of the end you know yeah and i think i i just will add that it's i now that i'm hearing
that she really has this passion for education as someone who has a passion for learning i'm
wondering if that's the connection between having all of these different passions because when you
want when you like when you when you see a value in just learning and and researching and gaining
knowledge like the world is your ocean there's so many things that you're interested in because you
just like the process of learning and then sharing that knowledge so i think that's why i was thinking
what you're what you're talking about with uh trying not not limiting yourself to one or the
other i think is is going to be gold for her and i think your passion is being able to experiment
and try and learn a lot of different things so um that's what i've experienced specifically on
rishi cup tv i don't do one or the other and it for some people watching my channel they might
really feel like gosh this is just all over the place and i hope it i hope it does find focus
more and more but i think my viewers are liking what i'm doing because i'm liking what i'm doing
and i have a lot of different interests i i think i would definitely encourage that
just uh everything you said is is brilliant yep okay yeah you said some things just were important
there were about liking what you're doing you're doing things you like to do and it'll it'll show
off like you are doing something only to make money or only to make this customer happy or
only because you think if they drop out then your company's not going to go anywhere you're
not going to do well uh you have to have back to the point from the maxwell you have to have that
passion um combined with the customer you don't you assistant service is interesting what you're
doing you need you need to change too many entrepreneurs box themselves into the same
thing and you need to constantly evolve your business
nice all right you ready for the next one yep all right trisha mahindra says hello evan i've
been watching your videos and you speak of values oh here it comes again i would like to know how
did you set your values and how do you stick to them irrespective of the condition you are in
great question oh i'm supposed to answer this question
okay values well i will i will definitely say that evan i attribute evan for sure
in me starting to um focus on what my values are figuring out what those are
and um so he's modeled that incredibly well for me i i love also this thing about values because
i think once you know what your values are then you can provide i don't know to me it's connected
if you want to provide value you've got to know what your values are um and i think that how do
you stick to them irrespective of the conditions you are in um starting out i mean i don't know if
all businesses do this or evan you encourage all businesses to start out doing this but i think if
you can write down somewhere what your values are and actually just have that as best as you can i
mean not being perfectionistic about it because you may not know everything you start but being
as clear as you can in the start about what your values are so that when the opportunities come
it's that much more easy to kind of not compromise on your values because you've already settled
within yourself what those values are um like i've heard you say evan you know i i love
entrepreneurs so it's going to be easy for me to stick you know basically if opportunities come and
and the people who want to work with me don't like entrepreneurs it's going to be that much
more easy for me to say no because we don't have that same value so the clearer you are
in the get-go about what your values are the easier it is to not compromise
cool um yeah you know for me it's all a belief obviously you know we talked about this
uh the values that you have have nothing to do with the business that you're in
uh the values that you have come from who you are as a human being and then you bring that
to any business that you go into and so for me belief came from my parents in terms of
i believe it was how do you identify your values and then how do you stick with them
no matter what right that was that was okay yeah that's right so uh
there's a lot that i could talk about i believe everybody has one word that defines who they are
and when you understand that you'll uh have a lot more success and you will live a life on purpose
i think it starts with in terms identifying your values the things that make you happy
what makes you happy uh you know in life what are the things that make you the happiest
things that make you the happiest and then trying to connect them so
you know for me my favorite movie is sea biscuit you know you guys you may have heard of it maybe
you like it maybe you hate it i don't know um but it's about this horse that everybody was against
and then you know miraculously turned it around in a jockey that was too big and you know all
these things that were wrong with with this horse that ended up you know winning and so just like
i love the comeback stories i love the the underdogs and that comes from my parents my parents
believed in me uh my parents always used to tell me that i was a uh kastrilli carmichael
i'm my mother's last name is kastrilli uh and i could do anything that i wanted anything i put
my mind to i could do and that was the source of belief my parents were not entrepreneurs and
don't have aspirations to be entrepreneurs and you know didn't really give me business advice
but they helped me a lot with that that aspect of it like understanding who who i was uh they forged
that in me and so it starts with thinking about what what makes you happy what connects all the
things in your life that make you come alive and if you have a hard time with that and i don't
kind of wish you went through this we're having a hard time kind of figuring out some of them
um what can help too is what's your anti-word like what's the thing that you hate the most in
other people uh who are the kinds of people that you would hate to have to spend any kind of
significant time with you know what what's the one characteristic about the people you hate that that
is in common and then you know the opposite of that is is your one word uh so finding that for
some people is easy uh and for others it's really hard and challenging uh for me it was not wasn't
fast it wasn't easy it took me it took me a while to figure it out but other people have insane
self-awareness and they just they figured out super quick uh and i'm kind of jealous of those
people what was the what was the tipping point when you really knew uh i think with anything
like the more you sleep on it when it comes down to values there's often decisions that you have
to make based off values and you know you make the right decision when you wake up the next day and
you feel good about it and you wake up the next day you feel even better about it uh you know the
the the sleep on it test is super effective at least i find and when i first came up with believe
i thought it was too big it's it's you know i need i need to make it more specific you know
maybe believe in entrepreneurs or believe in yourself or something like believe alone was
too big a word and then as i tried adding more things to it i i just didn't like any of it you
know and just to come back to believe i said well maybe i can do this maybe i can be about believe
um and you know there's other people who use believe before you know justin bieber had an
album believe and you know uh lots of musicians and artists have used believe before and that's
okay like i'm putting my own spin on it um and that's important so identifying it again for
some people is super easy it comes naturally in others it takes a long time to figure out
uh once you get it how do you stick with it no matter what that's that's the hard part and i
think that uh you know there's an expression about the devil always comes holding a bag of money
uh it's often you'll do things because uh you know there's this opportunity that looks good on paper
and you know there's a lot of money attached to it and so you're tempted
but then it's always it's almost always something that just sucks you know the deals that i took
just for money have never worked out never ever ever worked out it always come back to hit me uh
and i think i mean you learn that through mistakes like i don't think you can i don't think at the
start you just say uh i'm never gonna make a decision that doesn't tie me with
you know my core value i think you're gonna make mistakes and you're gonna learn from those
mistakes and then those mistakes will teach you to be better the next time you're less likely to
make mistakes next time around and so you don't have to be perfect like you don't have to put
this pressure on yourself to be perfect all the time make every right decision all the time
you've got to make mistakes okay
and yeah i mean i i've i've learned to stick to my
my gut and my values because i've i've in the past not done it and it's been painful
and so that pain you know means that now i'm gonna stick to it yeah that's so good
and even made mistakes along the way but it's helped it's the mistakes have helped you even
solidify more what your values are right this is a crazy long game games do not go this long
and we had a crazy setup too but here we go this is a giant stream
how long do these games usually last uh it can be from 20 minutes to 40 minutes
and it's still going and we're already at like 55 minutes plus it took a long time to get into
the game so anyway good we get to answer some extra questions good stuff all right uh next
question comes from now looks like okay i'm gonna go to nathan moraldo the drummer we've got another
another artist person and he says uh he his passion was drumming but then his parents
thought it would be best that it would just be a hobby and not an actual career so he quit he
quit music school and started a multi-level marketing opportunity that his parents i guess
kind of uh told him about and the multi-level marketing company is and involves flight tickets
hotels rental cars anyway he wants to know from you you know did he cheat himself out of music
he does have financial responsibilities so he's he's got very real demands in terms of
making money right now but you know did he cheat himself out of music
yeah okay so what do you got okay um i guess as someone who's doing music
yeah and every situation is so unique i mean um you know you you've talked a lot about
not you know don't don't make these crazy insane decisions that are gonna make you
like refinance your house and just all this craziness um so i would say if music can still
his passion he wants to still pursue this but he does have financial responsibilities is there
something that he can do every single day benefits a half hour a day to pursue the music
i don't know much about the multi-level marketing stuff i don't know if he's passionate about it if
he's not passionate about it i probably would say that's not the best place to be there's other ways
that you can probably get a job or find you know a way to support yourself without doing something
that you're not passionate about but music for sure is something that he can pursue each and
every day and it could grow into something that could support him um i think sometimes
two people do have passion for music but they might have i mean i don't know if this sounds
too harsh but i mean some people i as a vocal teacher i mean i did have students who like they
just wanted to pursue singing you know they wanted they wanted that to be their career but
it was clear that that was not going to be probably the best choice because they they just
didn't have an ability to sing um i don't know if you have different thoughts on this i know there's
a whole discussion about talent versus working hard but if you really feel like you've got a
talent for drumming and you really feel like you could do this and and go for it then i think you
should i i think i need to to hear a little bit more details about kind of like what he would
want to pursue specifically but that's my two cents i love it words of wisdom from rishi cup tv
right there uh for me i hate living with regret period and i try to do things
as much as possible to avoid living with regret i don't want to be the guy who's you know
90 years old looking back and saying i wish i did drumming or i wish i did you know whatever
whatever it is that you really want to do you know i wish i did that and uh
the next thing becomes well am i out of time like is it too late now you know because i've already
how old he is and there's all these responsibilities and you know a lot of people then
let that dictate their dreams uh and you still can't and it's understanding that you just need to
do it like you get started like rishi said every day you do something even if it's little every
day you're working on your job you know whether you're making youtube videos whether you're
trying to teach people you know whether you want to be in a band i don't know what your
long-term aspirations are around drumming maybe you haven't figured it out yet that's okay
but just uh just sitting there just the fact that you're wondering you know did i make a mistake
already shows the regret that you're living with and so it comes down to how long are you this is
going to happen for the rest of your life if you don't do something about it you will wonder for
the rest of your life and is that how you want the rest of your life to play out
wondering what could have been and for me that just that killed me that that like that idea
just kills me and i know it's scary right like it's easy to say but it's hard to actually because
it's very scary it doesn't mean you have to quit your job and it doesn't mean you have to
mortgage your house doesn't get to go full time it doesn't mean you know you have to give up on
your family doesn't mean now you know your wife has to support you guys it doesn't mean you have
you know all these assumptions that people make there's not gonna be any of that we still have
time you make time for things that are important you can still find time to make it happen my
computer just crashed you can still hear me yes all right oh we're back we're back my computer
crashed but we're back oh no that was frozen again but i didn't die so that's good is is
okay the game is back on no that's crazy this is the longest game of all time this is the craziest
first attempt at this stream ever this is great but that's good you get more questions in so uh
i'm gonna give two examples that might help with this because the first when i was
when i was in uh university i had an opportunity to join a software company where up until that
point all i wanted to do would be uh a banker like you look at my high school yearbooks and
that's what i want to do i'm going to be a banker banker banker banker then i had this opportunity
to to join a startup and i also had opportunities from banks that i really looked up to where i would
be earning you know 80 hundred thousand dollar starting salary and travel and do all the stuff
that i always thought i wanted to do but there was this nagging feeling in the back of my head that
oh man this is i'm not going to get another chance at this right like this is i could
always get another bank job but i don't know if i'll ever get another chance at doing this
and that was actually what made the difference for me understanding that i could always go back
i can always get another bank job but this i would regret not saying yes to and so even if
it didn't work out i gave myself a year and said i'm going to try this crazy thing for a year and
see how it works out and luckily it worked out you know i didn't have to go back and get a job
um wow but ever but it was hard you know it was easy these are you know my friends wanted those
jobs they were they were telling me this is this is stupid like why would we join this company now
and i was making 300 a month at that company you know i wasn't it was not making money where i
took down huge jobs to do this and it was just that feeling that you know i did not want to live
in regret i had to give the shot and see if i could make it work or not that's what that's what
and so now i try to use that as a as a buffer like as my mantra as a guiding principle as well
um and more recently i had an opportunity to work with an agency where somebody would you know
an agent represents me put me in deals get me you know put deals and uh other opportunities and
they needed uh some upfront money from me for training and historically i hate spending money
until i make money right i mean that right i made that comment earlier on and so like
do i break my own rule to do this and what it came down to was you know i would regret
if i didn't say yes and do this deal i would i would regret it i would regret it like i never
heard of another agency that does this before and i did not want that non-feeling so i broke
my rule of not spending money to spend the money on the training and and it worked out you know
thankfully it worked out uh but even if it didn't like even if it wasn't successful
uh i would still be okay with it because at least i tried and all it cost me was that financial
investment as opposed to the rest of my life worrying like what could have happened if i just
said yes to this wow and so anytime you have that feeling that you might regret this then do it
just do it you know and the more you get used to doing it the less scary it becomes to do it again
wow yep um so that that's really been a helping point for me and i hope that it can help him
start his drumming career absolutely we look forward to hearing a year from now
what you've been doing with your drumming yeah
all right um next question comes from
and uh okay this one was a little strange of an only because it seemed like you guys might this
might have been a reply so if you don't understand this we'll just what was the name
and then the last name is demarisk demarisk and like a n n a n n yep oh okay
and it says i would love last pass even more if it would launch for me
when i hit the command i put in the necessary time url etc but launched the site without me
having to find my password each time it doesn't do am i missing something oh last pass cool okay so
i love last pass is a tool that i use that i've used for oh man i don't know hold on it's been a
while now um and what it does is it remembers your passwords for you anytime you set it up and it also
um helps you generate passwords you don't have the same password for everything all the time
uh and so the way that it works is when you when you log into the site uh whenever you create a new
account wow amazing i wasn't i wasn't super hopeful i'll be honest well i had i had a i had
a terrible team uh especially one player but we won i contributed i wasn't the best i could be but
i contributed so good um good so this is our last question i wrap up on i like it um yes last pass
awesome tool uh when you log into a new website to create the account it'll say there's an option
there to have it help you generate a password which i usually use so i'm not using the same
password for everything and then um if you click on the advanced settings after you create it
it'll say like do you want last pass to remember this and you say yes it'll load a little window
and then in that window under advanced settings click you have to click on the arrow underneath
it says auto login which is a little check box and you check off so anytime that you come back
to that website you win every time um okay so yeah it's a technical one but um yeah we got it
and it's quick and we won hey hey pretty good so that's the end of our first stream thank you guys
for watching uh Rishi for people who want to learn more about you and find out about your channel
what's the best place to go youtube at rishi cup tv that's r-i-s-h-y-c-u-p-t-b i love it
sign it off continue to believe and we'll see you soon